[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kreisel
berichte und christian sievers
guten abend hinein wie abhängig wir sind
von dauernden facebook updates der
schönen bilder welt bei instagram und
dem kling der whatsapp mitteilungen das
lässt sich gerade gut im selbstversuch
testen alle diese dienste die alle zum
facebook imperium gehören sind seit
heute nachmittag weitgehend vom netz
gestört doch es gibt ein problem steht
da jetzt und das gilt auch für facebook
selbst nur was geklickt und geleitet
wird findet statt in den sogenannten
sozialen medien für ein netzwerk wie
facebook das unfassbar viel geld damit
verdient lautet deshalb die
entscheidende frage wie bringt man die
leute dazu möglichst viel zu klicken und
zu leiten die antwort am einfachsten
durch wut hass und spaltung so sagt das
eine die es wissen müsste francis horgen
hat selbst bei facebook gearbeitet in
der abteilung die gegend
falschinformationen vorgehen soll und
sie geht jetzt an die öffentlichkeit im
gepäck eigene studien des
internetgiganten zehntausende seiten
interner dokumente die ihren
ex-arbeitgeber enorm in schwierigkeiten
bringen könnten
ich habe immer wieder beobachtet dass es
interessenkonflikte gab bei der frage
was ist gut für die öffentlichkeit und
was ist gut für facebook und facebook
hat sich immer wieder für die eigenen
interessen entschieden zum beispiel mehr
geld zu verdienen die heutige version
von facebook heißt unsere gesellschaft
auseinander und führt zu ethnischer
gewalt auf der ganzen welt
das sind vorwürfe die mächtig wirbel
machen in den usa die ex managerin wird
morgen im parlament aussagen sie treffen
den internetgiganten in einer zeit in
der dessen praktiken auch der politik
zunehmend unheimlich werden konnten
berichtet
ein visionär der die welt mit
technologie beflügelt so inszeniert sich
mark zuckerberg ein image dass kratzer
bekommen hat
wer ist der chef eines unglaublich
mächtigen unternehmens mit drei
milliarden rosa doch eher handelt so als
ob er das fahrwerk seines flugzeuges
erst baut wenn es schon in der luft ist
facebook riskiere die sicherheit seiner
user und gefährde die demokratie
die reporterinnen cäcilia king und
schira frenkel werfen in ihrem buch an
ugly truth eine hässliche wahrheit mark
zuckerberg und co geschäftsführerin
sheryl sandberg einen skrupellosen
expansionskurs vor
der artikel stammt von einer
führungskraft er sprach von einer
hässlichen wahrheit um die realität bei
facebook zu beschreiben wie die
führungsriege wiederholt ähnliche
entscheidungen trifft und fehler in
ländern wie myanmar oder anderswo begeht
die dazu führen dass menschen getötet
werden
2017 startete das militär im januar eine
desinformationskampagne gegen die
muslimische rohingya minderheit
facebooks algorithmus hätte hass
verbreitet die gewalt eskalierte 25.000
menschen starben hunderttausende flohen
die konzernzentrale in kalifornien habe
warnungen von
menschenrechts-organisationen ignoriert
bis 2018 gab es nur fünf sie sprechen
die mitarbeiter innen für einen markt
von 18 millionen usern facebook facebook
braucht die beteiligung seiner user um
zu wachsen
sieht algorithmus zielt darauf ab user
zu binden spielt aufsehen erregen dass
nach oben das bedeutet dass er inhalte
priorisiert die emotionen erzeugen egal
ob mode traurigkeit light oder empörung
oftmals dinge die einen am meisten in
die irre führen oder das informieren
ein algorithmus der auch im vorfeld der
attacke auf das kapitol die zugriffe auf
facebook wachsen hieß so habe dieser
trump verloren gruppen empfohlen in
denen sich gewaltbereite demonstranten
organisierten
die autorinnen kommen zu einem
erstaunlichen schluss facebook habe
bereits vor dem 6 januar gewusst was
geplant war
sie waren in alarmbereitschaft wegen
diesen tag sie bemerkten dass personen
darüber sprachen waffen mitzubringen
viele posten fotos eigener waffen an
schrieben den bringe ich mit nach
washington
die algorithmische verstärkung von
emotionen dna von facebook stimmen die
eine abkehr von diesem modell sagte
bergs fordern würden ignoriert
fünf jahre recherche rund 400 interviews
die meisten davon mit mitarbeiter innen
das buch liegt den seelenzustand des
unternehmens offen
[Musik]
es war fast so als ob wir in einer
therapie mit ihnen saßen in der sie sich
jahrelange frustration und angst von der
seele redet
mark zuckerberg arbeitet derzeit an
seiner nächsten vision dem sogenannten
meta war's eine art digitale
parallelwelt es ist der ultimative traum
der werbeindustrie eine plattform auf
der user tag und nacht verbringen
facebook bestreitet dass das unternehmen
schlechte inhalte förderung der für die
außenkommunikation verantwortliche
manager nick clegg nennt die
anschuldigung lächerlich
unsere aufgabe ist es das schlechte zu
mildern es zu reduzieren und das gute zu
verstärken und genau darum geht es bei
unserer forschung
facebook erreicht mit seinen diversen
angeboten ein drittel der
weltbevölkerung die macht des
unternehmens kann man kaum überschätzen
ob sich etwas ändert wird am ende von
denen abhängen die facebooks gewinn
mehreren den investoren und den
werbekunden
in der deutschen politik heute ein
zwischen tag der herbstlich unschuldig
daherkommt in berlin an dem wir ihnen
diverse außenaufnahmen von gebäuden
zeigen weil hinter verschlossenen türen
an einer regierung für dieses land
gebastelt wird aber die bastler sich
nicht in die karten gucken lassen wollen
aus fernseh sicht ist es auch ein tag
der verzweifelten bilder was sicher
festzuhalten ist ist der zeitplan der
treffen gestern rot gelb rot grün und
schwarz gelb morgen schwarz grün fest
steht auch dass theo koll die situation
vor und hinter den kulissen für uns
beobachtet guten abend theorie stehen
wir denn aktuell lässt sich schon eine
richtung ablesen ja wir stehen
einerseits vor den türen wie eben
gezeigt und auch auf eine gewisse art um
einen politischen poker tisch herum wo
die spieler ja unterschiedlicher war vor
allem verdeckte blätter in der hand
halten wobei armin laschet ja
offensichtlich noch online spielen kann
also für ihn gibt es nur noch sieg- oder
alles weg dass laschet lager hofft jetzt
dass er morgen im gespräch mit den
grünen seine spiel künste zeigen könne
also als verhandlungsführer der auch den
anderen stiche und erfolge zugesteht und
da habe ich am ende dann selbst gewinnt
die grünen wiederum wollen morgen die
handlungsfähigkeit der union ausloten
also wieviel prokura hat armin laschet
eigentlich noch nach der ganzen
innerparteilichen kritik also kann er
wesentliche zugeständnisse machen und
dann auch in der union durchsetzen das
war ja das erfolgsgeheimnis bei den
jamaika behandlung in schleswig holstein
und ohne diese politische prokura so
hört man bei den grünen wird es nicht
gehen kann es dann sein theo dass ab
morgen die variante mit der union dann
auch bereits geschichte ist nämlich wenn
es bei den grünen wirklich probleme gibt
oder mit den grünen viel mehr also
möglich ist in diesen tagen natürlich
alles so dass beispielsweise aus dem
gespräch der union mit der fdp
offensichtlich vertrauliches
durchgestochen worden an die bild
zeitung und prompt kommentierte dann ein
fdp verhandler das feld auf liebe union
und es nervt da auch aus den unions
vorgesprächen berichtet wurde ist es
also nicht ganz abwegig davon auszugehen
dass die quelle jemand aus der union war
und genau so nahe liegen könnte sein
dass dieser jemand laschet durch die
indiskretion schaden wollte
beziehungsweise seine verhandlungs
schwächung in kauf genommen hat nach dem
morgigen gespräch wollen grüne und fdp
dann jeweils parteiintern die erste
runde der gespräche bewerten und dann
ihre ergebnisse miteinander vergleichen
und danach gibt es dann entweder weitere
vorgespräche oder schon eine
entscheidung über die richtung der dann
drei sondierungen ich gehe mal von außen
sonst morgen wieder sehen und hören
werden theo vielen dank für heute und
auch unsere nächste geschichte heute
abend spielt in bereichen deren
dimensionen wir uns kaum vorstellen
können die größte eigentlich
vertrauliche daten sammlung die einem
internationalen netzwerk von
investigativ journalisten je zugespielt
wurde die pandora papers und ihre folgen
hunderte regierungsvertreter amtsträger
oligarchen prominente aus aller welt
sollen geld in steueroasen versteckt
haben britta hilpert jetzt über einen
regierungschef direkt in unserer
nachbarschaft der jetzt besonders ins
visier gerät
andré barisch im pool seine frau in
ihrem garten
bürgernah trotz reichtum wollte der
tschechische ministerpräsident wirken
mit social media post von seinem
französischen anwesen nun zeigt sie ein
investigativ netzwerk als beleg für ein
fragwürdiges geschäft diese und weitere
immobilien kaufte der tschechische
ministerpräsident für 15 millionen euro
über briefkastenfirmen mit shine
krediten schwer nachvollziehbare
geldflüsse
unklar ist ob und wie illegal das war
klar ist fünf tage vor parlamentswahlen
bringt das barbisch in erklärungsnot
ich besitze nichts an frankreich ich
habe keine briefkastenfirma sagt er und
beteuert dann das maklerbüro empfahl den
kauf über anwälte abzuwickeln da gibt's
nichts illegales
gleichzeitig opfer und gesetzestreuer
bürger so geben sich nun viele bekannte
persönlichkeiten mit macht und geld der
britische ex premier blair der
ukrainische staatspräsident zia lenski
der jordanische könig abdullah und noch
nicht sie sind in erklärungsnot denn
auch wenn verschleiern an sich nicht
illegal ist so stellt sich doch eine
frage warum nutzt man diese sehr
komplizierten strukturen die dort
stattfinden und dafür kann es ja auch
durchaus legale nachvollziehbare gründe
geben aber gerade seine anonymität
gerade so eine versteckte situation
hilft natürlich auch möglichen
geldfälschern und organisierte
kriminalität versteck zu bleiben für
politiker gelten in tschechien strengere
regeln habe ich hätte den besitz
offenlegen müssen das verlangt das
gesetz die polizei prüft nun die
vorwürfe sie tut das bei barbisch nicht
zum ersten mal denn für sein hotel
storchennest bekam barbisch zu unrecht
eu-geld die polizei empfiehlt seit
monaten einer anklage der neuerliche
skandal könnte den wahlausgang verändern
seine stammwähler werden sich nicht
irritieren lassen aber gleichzeitig ist
es für andere vielleicht
eine skandal zu viel
das könnte alles ändern zugunsten der
opposition
[Musik]
weiter 14 uhr öffnen die wahllokale bis
dahin ist tschechien eine politische
schlammschlacht garantiert
wahrscheinlich sogar darüber hinaus denn
keine partei wird die absolute mehrheit
erringen trotz der skandale hat babbel
chancen regierungschef zu bleiben
so und jetzt hier einen erster
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem montag 11
da bleiben wir beim thema geld die
rechnungshöfe von bund und ländern
dringen auf ein beibehalten der
schuldenbremse auf ihrer herbstkonferenz
arbeiten sie an einer erklärung in der
sie eine nachhaltige finanzpolitik
fordern wollen die berliner gastgeberin
klingeln sprach vor dem treffen von
einer enormen staatsverschuldung deshalb
müsse man selbst bei investitionen
prioritäten setzen die schuldenbremse
dürfte auch bei den anstehenden
koalitionsverhandlungen eine wichtige
rolle spielen ab heute lockern auch
berlin und bayern die korona regeln an
schulen in der hauptstadt den fällt die
masten pflicht im unterricht bis zur
sechsten klasse in bayern komplett
fachleute bewerten das unterschiedlich
die einen halten die aufhebung für
überfällig die anderen für verfrüht laut
dem robert-koch-institut sind 35 prozent
der 12 bis 17 jährigen vollständig
geimpft dem quote bei der gesamten
bevölkerung liegt bei 64 7 prozent für
unter 12-jährige wurde noch kein
impfstoff zugelassen
seit heute empfiehlt die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde ema eine so genannte
booster impfung also eine dritte spritze
zur auffrischung dafür komme der korona
impfstoff von beyond eckpfeiler in
betracht mindestens sechs monate nach
der zweiten dosis in deutschland hatte
die ständige impfkommission die
auffrischung bereits empfohlen für
menschen mit schwacher immunabwehr
japan hat einen neuen regierungschef das
parlament wählte den früheren
außenminister kissinger zum
premierminister der 64 jährige kündigte
ein milliardenschweres
aktionsprogramm an und zog die
anstehenden neuwahlen auf den 31 oktober
vor über geschieht das erfolg dürfte
auch seine corona politik entscheiden
denn schlechtes krisenmanagement war ein
rücktrittsgrund seines vorgängers sogar
der nobelpreis für medizin geht in
diesem jahr in die usa an die
molekularbiologen david julius und adam
katapultieren das stockholmer karolinska
institut ehrt sie für ihre erklärung was
genau in zellen geschieht damit menschen
wärme und berührung fühlen dieses wissen
werde genutzt um neue
behandlungsmöglichkeiten zu entwickeln
unter anderem gegen chronische schmerzen
einen ausführlichen bericht über ihre
forschung sehen sie im heute-journal
update um 0 uhr 15
der stolz der deutschen marine das
segelschulschiff gorch fock ein
symbolbild das die letzten jahre ganz
gut zusammenfasst die
bundesverteidigungsministerium spricht
heute von sehr schweren stunden
tatsächlich gab es wohl eher lange
momente in denen unklar war ob die gorch
fock überhaupt jemals wieder unterwegs
sein würde auf den weltmeeren zehn
millionen euro waren mal vereinbart um
das schiff flott zu machen am ende sind
es
135 millionen geworden und ein fall für
die justiz
aber jetzt ist sie zurück im heimathafen
kiel hebestreit berichtet
auf der gorch fock kommentiert kapitän
nils brandt persönlich das anlegemanöver
des generalüberholten schulschiffes der
deutschen marine mit dem heck voran geht
es zum liegeplatz im kieler marinehafen
[Musik]
2232 tagen abwesenheit sind crew und
kommen dann froh ihr schiff nach hause
gebracht zu haben
war wieder schön hier nach kiel zurück
zu kommen und damit letztendlich auch in
unseren angestammten liegeplatz der sind
seit freitag ohne unseren namen trägt da
zu sein und einfach wieder zeugen stück
normalität zurückkehren zu können
sie schießen salut meiner einfahrt in
den hafen wohl auch aus erleichterung
und selbst in der marine viele
bezweifelt hatten dass die gorch fock
noch mal schwimmen würde jetzt ist sie
wieder da und damit nimmt eine zeit
voller pleiten pech und pannen doch noch
ein glückliches ende
2015 waren bei reparaturarbeiten im dock
schwere schäden festgestellt worden die
kosten explodierten eine werft machte
pleite staatsanwälte ermitteln auch
wegen korruption nach für seine kuh
bekommen ein brand in hand ins feuer
wenn es um irgendwelche
korruptionsaffären geht auf der gorch
fock denn es ist falsch gewesen es war
ungleich folgt vielleicht aber meine
besatzung und nicht hatten damit leider
nichts zu tun oder gott sei dank nichts
zu tun
der versprecher zeigt wie angefasst
brand ist er selbst auf beförderungen
verzichtet hat um während der
sechsjährigen werft zeit am schiff zu
bleiben außerdem glaube ich wäre es ein
schlechter zeitpunkt gewesen vor 23
jahren das schiff zu verlassen die
besatzung im stich zu lassen und das war
auch ein wesentlicher grund warum ich
gesagt ich bleibe
und so ist die gorch fock jetzt von
grund auf erneuert was die steuerzahler
fast das 14fache der veranschlagten zehn
millionen euro kostet außerdem ist auch
der laufende betrieb
die gorch fock wird auch in zukunft
millionen weiterhin kosten ob das
wirklich auch notwendig ist das muss die
marine beantworten sagte sie falls das
dieses projekt völlig aus dem ruder
gelaufen ist trotzdem hält die marine
ein schulschiff für das teambuilding zur
see für unerlässlich und hoch im norden
sind die menschen vor allem pro die
gorch fock wieder zu sehen ich freue
mich dass sie wieder da ist obwohl ich
finde die kosten sind zu hoch geworden
natürlich spielt geld eine rolle aber
das können wir anfangen mit berliner
flughafen stuttgart 21 11 wo wollen wir
da anfangen wo aufhören
auch ein vorwurf von umweltschützern auf
dem schiff sei illegal geschlagenes teak
holz verwendet worden beschäftigt die
justiz
davon unbeeindruckt laufen die
vorbereitungen für den ersten
ausbildungsjahr rund um die kanaren wohl
die letzte fahrt unter dem kommando von
kapitän bleibt
unser nächstes thema klimaneutraler
treibstoff für ihre flugzeuge alleine
wird das klimaproblem der airlines nicht
lösen aber es wäre ein schritt in die
richtige richtung und seit heute kann
man den konjunktiv wäre dabei weglassen
denn die weltweit erste
produktionsanlage für nachhaltiges
kerosin ist an den start gegangen im
nördlichen emsland wollen sie flugreisen
klimafreundlicher machen wie viel
zukunft darin liegt muss man niemandem
sagen gleichzeitig zeigt das projekt
aber auch wie viele herausforderungen
noch zu meistern sind und wie viele neue
probleme entstehen elisabeth schmid und
fabian köhler bericht
unscheinbar kaum größer als ein paar
container durch diese anlage mitten im
emsland könnte den luftverkehr
klimaneutraler werden lassen sie
produziert co2 neutrales synthetisches
rohöl als basis für kerosin bislang sei
das weltweit einmalig so der betreiber
entsprechend groß das interesse und die
hoffnung die hier an allen ecken spürbar
ist es geht um die zukunft des
luftverkehrs
auch dass fliegen muss klimaneutral
werden und diese anlage zeigt jetzt wie
das funktionieren kann hier wird kerosin
mit hilfe erneuerbarer energien
hergestellt und das ist der weg den wir
in zukunft brauchen doch es ist nicht
die politik sind nicht die großen
energiekonzerne die den traum vom grünen
fliegen vorantreiben es ist eine private
klimaschutzorganisation die das fliegen
aus eigenem antrieb finanziert durch
spenden verändern will und sie wollen
auch zeigen dass deutschland zeichen
setzen kann
wenn man im ausland mit der luftfahrt
oder auch mit anderen personen über
dieses thema spricht dann schauen ja oft
verständnislos an wissen gar nicht wo
man spricht von daher ist das glaube ich
schon jetzt gerade wenn das weltweit
berichtet wird so ein startpunkt wo
wahrscheinlich auch ingenieure in
anderen ländern anfangen zu sagen hoch
damit vielleicht was verpasst die anlage
produziert das synthetische kerosin aus
wasser und co2 das co2 kommt zum einen
aus einer biogasanlage die
lebensmittelreste verwertet und zum
anderen einfach aus der umgebungsluft
insgesamt wird so viel co2 im
produktionsprozess gebunden wie später
vom flugzeug wieder ausgestoßen wird der
für die herstellung benötigte strom
kommt aus windkraft deswegen geht dieses
kerosin als klimaneutral was wir hier
heute sehen ist ein erster wichtiger
schritt aber bis zur klimaneutralität
ist das noch ein weiter weg brauchen
viel viel mehr und auch größere anlagen
wie wir sie heute hier sehen aber daran
arbeiten wir schon so reicht die
jahresmenge hier gerade einmal für einen
flug von frankfurt nach singapur
deutschland schreibt eine beimischung
des biokraftstoffes ab 20 26 per gesetz
vor der markt braucht das grüne kerosin
und so kommt bewegung in die
luftfahrtbranche
deswegen haben wir uns jetzt auch
vorgenommen 2050 42 neutral zu sein aber
2030 schon die hälfte der emissionen
einzusparen und dazu müssen wir einfach
direkt anfangen noch kostet der liter
grünes kerosin rund fünf euro mit
steigender produktion wird der preis
fallen und für die flugbranche bezahlbar
fliegen würde grüner
so wir bleiben beim sprit aber zurück
auf der erde nun bei einer situation die
aus der entfernung betrachtet zunehmend
absurd wirkt kaiser es geht um die
versorgungskrise in großbritannien dort
helfen seit heute rund 200 soldaten bei
der treibstoff auslieferung vor allem im
großraum london und in südengland haben
viele tankstellen kein benzin mehr
hintergrund der krise ist ein eklatanter
mangel an lkw fahrern der sich auch auf
andere güter auswirkt hamsterkäufe haben
das problem verstärkt
in der ostsee pipeline nord stream 2
fließt seit heute das erste gas einer
der beiden stränge wird schrittweise
befüllt um notwendige tests
durchzuführen wann der eigentliche
transport beginnt ist noch unklar durch
die pipeline sollen die russischen
gaslieferungen nach deutschland
verdoppelt werden sie ist umstritten
weil moskau die leitung für
geopolitische zwecke missbrauchen könnte
eva grant dieser vollmundige name dürfte
in diesen tagen einigen wie hohn klingen
denn der chinesische immobilienkonzern
hat so hohe schulden dass die finanzwelt
auf dem ganzen globus hinschaut heute
wurde sogar der handel mit ever grant
aktien ausgesetzt was steckt dahinter
frank bethmann in frankfurt es deutet
sich ein deal an hobson ein konkurrent
will anteilig eine grand tochter
übernehmen und dafür gut fünf milliarden
dollar bezahlen beide konzerne haben
sich bis zur stunde noch nicht dazu
geäußert doch selbst wenn es dazu käme 5
milliarden dollar wäre nicht die rettung
sie würde nur zeit erkaufen es sind die
bilder einer krise halbfertige
wohnkomplexe und keiner weiß ob über
gransee jäh zu ende bauen wird ein
angeschlagener gigant der superlative
kein anderes immobilien unternehmen
weltweit hat mehr schulden direkt und
indirekt zählt man die vielen zulieferer
dazu gibt es an vier millionen menschen
arbeit und 1,4 millionen kunden haben in
immobilien investiert in die sie
vielleicht nie einziehen können wütende
verzweifelte chinesen in der evergreen
zentrale proteste die das potenzial
haben den sozialen frieden zu gefährden
peking in der zwickmühle greift die
staatsregierung nicht ein drohen unruhen
greift sie ein senden sie ein falsches
signal eva brand ist zu groß um
fallengelassen zu werden ein
freifahrtschein für weiteres
unkontrolliertes wachstum der dax geht
in deckung verliert 120 punkte oder 0,8
prozent ebenso schwächer die wall street
auch dort dann am abend deutliche
kursverluste sein kern diverse frank an
der kalifornischen küste breitet sich
ein ölteppich aus grund ist eine
undichte pipeline südlich von los
angeles
das öl verseucht bereits 33
quadratkilometer wasser und hat beliebte
strände erreicht dort wurden auch
verschmierte tiere angespült viele von
ihnen sind verändert das leck konnte
noch nicht vollständig abgedichtet
werden wie es entstand ist noch unklar
deutsch-russische zusammenarbeit
deutsch-russische romantik in dresden
ist da gerade etwas besonderes zu
erleben vier jahre miteinander hat
deutsche und russische museumsleute zu
freunden gemacht einen kunst austausch
ermöglicht wie es ihnen so noch nie gab
und für alle interessierten eine schau
nach sachsen gebracht die brücken
schlägt caspar david friedrich und
alexander iwanow aus dresden berichtet
steffen moritz
träume von freiheit für künstler ein
ganz besonderer antrieb ihre gedanken
und gefühle auszudrücken
wenn es sich dabei um für russische und
deutsche künstler handelt und um ein
gemeinschaftsprojekt beider länder
bekommt diese ausstellung unweigerlich
auch eine politische dimension
also halt eine ausstellung in politisch
zu komplizierten zeiten kann vielleicht
einen weg auch in die zukunft weisen
also einen weg wie man wieder
herausfinden kann aus dieser
kompliziertheit und verstrickt hat
unsere beziehungen und das zumindest die
kultur der anderen seite oft gar nicht
so anders ist zeigt diese ausstellung
deutscher romantiker wie caspar david
friedrich und ludwig richter mal in
ihrer oft düsteren und manchmal auch
träumerischen bedanken
doch schaut man auf die bilder der bei
uns weitgehend unbekannten russischen
romantiker erkennt man die gleichen
sehnsüchte und fragen der zeit
was ist heimat was meine identität
welche rolle spielen politik und
religion im leben
europa war nach der französischen
revolution geprägt von massiven
einschränkungen der bürgerrechte die
träume von freiheit
verflogen
die freiheit der landschaft die ja oft
bei friedrich unbegrenzt über die bild
grenzen hinaus fortgesetzt zu verstehen
ist das ist eine utopie von freiheit in
einer zeit die auf politischem und frei
ist wo man oft auch gar nicht seine
politische anschauung erwähnen konnte
allein schon wegen des titels war sie im
april als sie zuerst in moskau gezeigt
wurde ein publikumsrenner der titel
träume von freiheit war ein wunsch
unseres russischen kuratoren teams und
es waren sehr sehr viele junge menschen
in der ausstellung die in tiefem ernst
dies als sehr existenziellen kommentar
zur eigenen zeit gelesen haben auch ein
wunsch von russischer seite
stararchitekt daniel libeskind der mit
seiner gestaltung die räume sprechen
lässt enge und freiheit mit einer art
labyrinth erlebbar macht bis 6 es ist
eine erfahrung für die besucher die
bilder nicht nur im geschlossenen raum
zu erleben sondern als komplex aus
identität nation heimat kindheit alles
dinge in denen wir uns wiederfinden
zumindest auf kultureller ebene habe man
erkannt dass es mehr gemeinsamkeiten als
unterschiede gebe
und damit verabschieden uns für heute
sagen tschüss bis morgen und wünschen
allen ein schild
[Musik]
ein kunde und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter die serie der tiefs reist noch
nicht ab und auf dieses tief hier im
süden folgt schon das nächste aus
westlichen richtungen und bringt hier
regen mit sehen sie in blau ansonsten
haben es immer noch mit dem sehr
umfangreichen hoch über russland zu tun
oder das blockiert weiterhin und auch in
den nächsten tagen schauen wir auf die
nacht und da wird es im süden regnen und
auch nach osten hin nach westen lockert
teilweise auf uns zeigen sich auch mal
die sterne bei tiefsten temperaturen von
sechs grad in den mittelgebirgen im
westen deutschlands 9 grad an den alpen
noch am mildesten im ost mit zwölf grad
ja und schon morgen am vormittag nach
süden hin viel regen und auch nach osten
das ganze verlagert sich langsam nach
nordosten in richtung rhein und ems da
gibt es viel sonnenschein zu nachmittag
ändert sich das aber da zieht es mit dem
neuen tief zu und es gibt neuen regen
nach osten hin kann es auch mal blitzen
und donnern die höchsten werte dort bis
22 grad am niederrhein 19 grad oder an
denen alpen 12 grad alles was sie hier
in grünen sehen da gibt es viele wolken
im tagesverlauf da ist es also kühler
die kommenden tage am mittwoch ist es
noch nass mit regen im osten allerdings
etwas aufgelockerter 10 bis 17 grad und
ab donnerstag wird es trockener freitag
leichter temperaturanstieg aber
insgesamt wenig änderungen damit ein
schöner abend